cuál de los siguientes números es mayor
un tercio o un quinto pausa este vídeo e
intenta responder muy bien pensemos en
esto juntos la forma en que puedo pensar
mejor en esto es visualizando lo así que
imaginemos un entero esto es un entero y
luego digamos que este es otro entero
voy a tratar de hacer estos rectángulos
del mismo tamaño como representaríamos
un tercio
bueno dividiríamos todo esto en tres
secciones iguales
intentaré dividirlo en tres secciones
iguales así que tenemos tres secciones
iguales justo aquí se supone que son
tres secciones iguales están dibujados a
mano así que tratan de verlo así pero
una de estas tres secciones iguales es
igual a un tercio entonces esto es un
tercio y qué pasa con un quinto trataré
de dividir este entero en cinco
secciones iguales uno
cuatro y cinco secciones iguales y un
quinto sería sólo uno de estos quintos
justo aquí y cuando lo comparamos que es
más grande un tercio o un quinto y si
aún no es obvio podría arrastrar esto
para que podamos compararlos
directamente y se puede ver muy
claramente que un tercio cubre más del
entero es una fracción más grande del
entero que un quinto entonces un tercio
es mayor que un quinto quizás hayan
notado un patrón interesante o podrían
comenzar a pensar en un patrón es
posible que hayan tenido la intención
cuando vieron un 5 aquí 5 es mayor que 3
pero un quinto es menor que un tercio o
un tercio es mayor que un quinto y eso
es generalmente cierto cuanto mayor sea
el denominador la fracción será menor
cuál es la razón que estamos dividiendo
el entero en las partes iguales de modo
que si solo estamos dividiendo en tres
si es uno de tres del entero o si es una
de las tres partes iguales del entero va
a ser más grande que una de las cinco
partes iguales
con base en esto como comparar y amos
estos dos números como comparar y amos
dos tercios con dos quintos bueno es la
misma idea un tercio es más grande que
un quinto entonces dos tercios
definitivamente será mayor que dos
quintos y puedes verlo aquí dos tercios
es esto mientras que aquí tenemos dos
quintos y puedo hacer otro ejemplo que
ni siquiera dibujado como comparar y
amos 4 sobre 6 con 4 sobre 8 4 sextos
contra cuatro octavos bueno es la misma
idea un sexto es más grande que un
octavo un sexto es mayor que un octavo
porque el denominador aquí es más
pequeño tenemos el mismo numerador pero
el denominador es más pequeño entonces
cuatro de las cosas más grandes serán
mayores que cuatro de las cosas más
pequeñas así que cuatro sextos es mayor
que cuatro octavos